[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys we got brandon lee
over here
but today we are doing a hot seat so
hot see obviously i'm sure you've done a
hot seat at least once in your life
maybe
oh [ __ ] virgin hot seat i don't even
know what that like what's that meal me
neither man this is a the targaryen seat
so pretty much all we're gonna do is
just fire a bunch of questions at you
just answer truthfully or live
whatever's just more entertaining you'll
see why it gets we're gonna warm up into
it we're gonna we'll keep mad cool cold
just add some dry ice here bart's the
king of dry questions we're gonna ask
some chill [ __ ] and then from there
we'll kind of work our way up to
temperature all right and when you win
you get a title fight um i haven't been
here in a long time can i get a [ __ ]
intro please bro geo's here too guys
thank you oh yeah
[Applause]
okay got it
why does
all right
what's
your favorite color boxing gloves hmm
that's cold
huh
he feels like he's like walking on
eggshells you like the red ones the
white this is like a setup or something
like this
that is that's my jab that's my job
you're right that's that's a very
interesting first question response
actually we've never had anybody go i
think you're setting me up for something
like he's gonna cause he knows i gotta
find iq he's like
he's like round one ain't the real
the real game to come out around one but
probably probably white really i just
lose so you can see the blood bro did
you give them a pair of the white
barbell gloves yeah you did
have you ever worn them
yes yes
no i think my mom put them on hey my mom
did put them on i'm sorry she's like
hitting the bag though all right cool
can you send me a picture of that
brandon lee's mom y'all check it out
that's so sick do you have any uh um
pre-fight traditions just some like
weird quirky rituals yeah um
i've been wearing the same socks the
same uh yeah since you were nine years
old
i think since like like 2019 like
there's this uh
this company sent me a pair of socks
and they're like they're just white
socks and they have like i don't know
what they say it's like asian writing
and it's like a red because my favorite
color is red but you think you like
white gloves he likes white gloves but
his colors let's see the blood bro you
ask favorite pair of boxing glove colors
um
do you have a girlfriend i do cool how
long have you been together uh five
years wow
nice man how'd you meet her high school
high school sweetheart
what's up with fighters and high school
sweethearts
i don't know why you're pointing at me
bro cause you're a [ __ ] high school
sweetheart fighter yeah you married your
high school i did i did over 13 years or
something right yeah 12 years loser
something up i guess did she go to every
fight
um
she's gone to the last the most recent
ones yeah or is it like is it hard for
her to watch or she's just like he's
gonna [ __ ] this full up anyway yeah i
feel like yeah i feel like my mom she's
like she can't really watch it but for
her she thought she probably thinks like
i'm [ __ ] invisible or something nice
[Laughter]
out of the 200 something fights in the
amateurs did you lose any of them i did
i was the worst one i really think there
was a worse one it was more like it was
a close flight but by points or
something yeah all my points what what's
the last fight you had that you were
actually no what's your most proud
performance that you had in a fight i
was professional yeah or amateur so i
really don't know but probably
i could buy uh my best knockout
it's probably back in uh 2021 in march i
thought i'd do the name santiago you've
been you you've been fighting since a
kid right since and then your parents
told you don't go and fight on the
streets but have you ever got into a
street fight before no never have you
been close to one and you're just like i
gotta [ __ ] chill because this guy's
pissing me off no never no damn no one's
ever tried to punk you like at a bar or
anything you got into an argument or
like just
like man [ __ ] this guy man
how is that like i said like when i
whenever i go in public i just mind my
business and
yeah if you weren't fighting what would
you be doing
probably what i'm doing now go to school
and
probably go get like a part-time job
somewhere
that sounds incredibly boring
i thought it was awesome
when you get when you get ready in front
of the mirror you ever blow yourself a
kiss
i don't blow myself a kiss but i
probably flex in the mirror hell yeah
dude you know just from the day that
we've been hanging out though what i
like about you brandon is that you
are basically very honest like you don't
try he tells the truth here yeah like no
they're like
like like a lot of people try to play it
up where like it's like if they were
given that question to be like oh yeah
you know i got big [ __ ] dreams and
[ __ ] you know i'm trying to do this it's
like no you don't want to hustle
like don't come in here and then he's
just like unapologetically who he is
he's like you know what yeah i just want
to [ __ ] be a [ __ ] you know work at
tsa and [ __ ] you know
or whatever right yeah and i'm like
that's [ __ ] sick
even if we we threw the whole barbell
glove question at you he's all like not
ever [ __ ] warm
he doesn't [ __ ] [ __ ] he doesn't
be like yeah man they're so great like
people will [ __ ] lie they'll be like
thanks for the gloves bart i [ __ ] use
them they were so good quality [ __ ] you
know i had them on just outside i had to
take them off yeah i [ __ ] drove with
those boxing gloves bro you know like i
love them i go to sleep with them use it
as a pillow nah like you say that [ __ ]
that's what i think is [ __ ] awesome
even like yo did you watch jk news [ __ ]
no never in
[ __ ] no i didn't watch jk
what's up what's the um
least amount of money you ever made on a
fight at least
getting warm
probably when i first started housing
like four stacks that's the least bro
that's the least that's still a lot is
that for win and show
or do you guys do it that way
when you when your first fight you guys
do it like uh money to win money to show
or is it just straight purse straight
person oh [ __ ]
is that like okay wait what yeah what's
the purse money you make after i'm
assuming
that's not what i was gonna ask because
i know what a purse is but what's a
stack a hundred a thousand thousand
right four thousand four thousand yeah
that was my question wow when um someone
wins a purse is that like the title like
price
or like is that the price of the day
like whoever wins the the whole [ __ ]
tournament no just like um some
professional professional boxing if him
him and i were to fight we could get a
purse so whatever he'll get paid
whatever i get picked he'll be the a
side how about a wallet do you get a
wallet
is it an lv purse i'd wish i'm gonna
turn up a little bit the temperature a
little bit
out of all the combat sports which one's
kind of the wackest
good question
so you got boxing which what do you
think won't even [ __ ] work bro
grappling jiu-jitsu
okay ninjutsu aikido taekwondo karate
kung fu karate oh my god
honest bro honest brandon is that karate
dude
get that
[ __ ] your [ __ ] kimonos and get them
over there well that's why because like
when you think of karate you think of
like some like generic white dude
teaching karate or something like that
honestly dojo [ __ ] bro like minnie mouse
that [ __ ] cobra kai from yeah whoa
probably
uh
maybe after boxing just to [ __ ] around
but i probably wouldn't compete who's
the weakest professional boxer in the
game right now oh good question like
overrated said all right told you i
ain't trying to say that again
besides that person who's the other one
[ __ ] jake paul logan paul yeah all
day call them out if there's a
who's a fighter that you think has a big
name that you'd be like if i fought that
dude i'd knock that [ __ ] out i
don't know this is just like the box
inside of me but like there's a lot of
times where i'm watching dudes i'm like
man you don't know how to fight exactly
as a competitor right like you'd be like
i can knock all these guys out i'll
smash these guys there's a lot of guys
yeah
i'll take that answer earlier
if you had to cheat to win a fight how
would you do it
would you go headbutt
you got you got you got uh
seven days
leading up to it because i don't know
some people start it could be steroids
it could be like packing the gloves with
[ __ ] but how would you if you if you
needed to cheat someone was going to pay
you to cheat
how would you
horse shoes in your gloves or shoes in
your gloves
try to [ __ ] somebody up like that no
there's only times where they do a horse
hair actually horse hair
on the gloves
it's just a furry ass clown it's just
got a mane something doesn't look right
they'll get a glove and they'll they'll
gut it and put like horse hair in it oh
so it's dinner
i don't know maybe like
there's two ways you can look at it
uh
probably like the steroids or something
so i can like have better endurance
or you could like wrap it wrap your
hands a certain way so you can hit
harder
like turn your hand into like a cast
like when um turn your head into a cast
margarita uh kodo that's what oh that's
right i saw that bunch of paper mache
dude that crazy that was that's why they
gotta check everything huh just pin
yourselves so like while you're you're
getting a hand drive there's a dude
standing right there and he's like oh
you can't do that oh you can't use that
much tape oh you do this one from each
camp on the other side yeah so let's say
this is my team i can send you over
there to go watch him oh it's tight
how did they miss it how did they miss
it when the dude like put plaster or
like when they did if there's a guy
watching i don't know uh he could have
been like oh i didn't go to the bathroom
or something today's video is brought to
you by upstar
think of all the things that you could
be doing right now if you didn't have a
high interest loan or credit card debt
well upstart can make your dreams a
reality by helping you pay off that debt
quickly and easily upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether you're
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debts or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment and that makes it easier upstart
knows that you're more than just your
credit score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart considers your income and
current employment to get you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you could see your rate up
front for loans from 1 000 to up to 50
000
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
wow so find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com off the record and make sure
to use the url below so they know that
we sent you go to upstart.com
off the record and the loan amount will
be determined by your credit income and
certain other information that you put
on the loan application go to
upstart.com
off the record all right for a billion
dollar purse all right oh [ __ ] billion
dollars with the wallet so i made the
wallet
will you fight to the death oh yeah
like you gotta kill or you get killed
and then for a billion dollars
who am i fighting someone that makes you
sweat i don't know someone who you feel
like i don't know if i could win
challenge like another channel not like
someone that you know you could [ __ ] up
but someone you're just like
i don't know if i could beat this dude
but like i'ma try
and then one of you gotta die
damn you're down yeah i think i might be
down
a billion dollars the way i'm looking at
though is like i'm gonna [ __ ] murder
someone so me i mean yeah but it's
allowed it's legal i love that [ __ ]
mindset bro he didn't say i might get
murdered he's like i'm gonna [ __ ]
have to live with me killing somebody
that's
because i believe in my skills that much
damn
well you gotta because i saw how
mr mohammed ali spoke i was like if he
wasn't a boxer you'd be like you are
such a narcissist i hate you
but like when it comes to athletes
you're just like the confidence i love
it i love it
damn
what do you do what do you do to uh
to to have that kind of like mindset and
confidence because i feel like the
normal world is a
full of [ __ ] and then athletes they
have a mind that's like nah man you
can't [ __ ] me up i'm the best i think
just uh there's boxing in general i mean
at a young age
i mean
one little kid you know hits another
little kid makes your nose bleed and get
a black eye revenge that's what i did
and um
i don't know it just like kind of like
shaped me who i am like so for you the
confidence you're saying is is from the
wins like from actually being able to do
it and you're just like [ __ ] i'm just
[ __ ] winning from the i mean it's
from the wins from my past uh
the amateur career plus the training so
i know that you know i believe i'm in
shape and all that yeah
what's your greatest fear my greatest
fear
it's not me losing it's not even getting
knocked out it's like so probably like
what my dad's gonna think or something
oh
like this calls you piece of [ __ ] you're
up ball there's your asian coming out if
if i taped one of your eyes shut did
that go beat you
that's a very good question that's a
very good question
because i don't think so damn what the
[ __ ] there's the times i could answer
that there's been times where i'd be
[ __ ] sparring yeah and i get like
thumbed in the eye or something and i
can't see like it's already blurred yeah
so i was like you got [ __ ] one eye
but you can still feel it like you kind
of see where everything is yeah
how fast do you think you can knock bart
out
if you guys and can we see it no i can't
like five because i was like you know
250. yeah i bet you no no but that's
pretty bad
he's got a big head for sure you'll
knock me out how much do it what 200 200
you don't [ __ ] wait 200 for real yeah
200 you're so sexy
really 200 yeah yeah how much do you
think he weighs like 230 250 yeah right
no that's what it looks like
no he'll knock me out
i don't know how that should work not
from fighting when was the last time you
cried
i think like sometime last year or
something
i don't know why
don't you know why i don't even know why
you're a gangster dude this dude is gay
do you think that's gonna work if like
let's say
going back to the cheating conversation
this scenario like let's say let's say i
get like just trying to learn how to
cheat if i'm fighting a boxer right
so they already checked my hands that's
not gonna work uh they see if there's
horse hair that's not gonna work but
right before i get in the ring i have my
coach put like tiger balm like a big a
big wad right here and a big wad right
here and when we get up in the clinch i
try to figure out a little put a little
bit in there oh and then now you get
both of them
other eyes oh do you think that'd be
like do you have something that will
work in the ring he has tiger bomb on
both eyes and the breath can't tell he's
like oh these guys
smell kind of funny but not really i
mean as soon as you get in the ring the
ref comes and they check you out they
check they i think they rub your arms
like that they smell your elbows
so the answer is no bart that would
never no they don't smell you but i mean
[ __ ] if someone's watching this probably
you just gave him an idea
i'll just put it like that
smells like [ __ ] no you put it right
here you put it in your elbow right grab
my arms i try to feel my arms
yep they're good
okay sometimes spiders get away with
that
should be a [ __ ] cheating consultant
dude that's next level
i got a hot ass question all right
all right all right
[ __ ] would you [ __ ] up a girl oh cause
right now all right in a professional
fight right and right now
there's been a whole like gender thing
right where there's like uh you know
transgender whatever going in mixing
sports even in fighting right
and then they're like technically you
can't call them girl anymore because now
uh they want to be called boy or or male
so then
you go toe-to-toe because let's say like
[ __ ] maybe because you got matched up
like would you be able to go through
with that and there's the billion dollar
purse no that's just too much that's the
twist that's afterwards billion dollars
i [ __ ] up a girl for a [ __ ] 1 million
so like
that's still kind of a rush okay never
mind so it's like it's a legit fight
yeah it's the next match it's legit
because she's a transgender girl or
whatever yeah it's a legit fight winner
or they win yeah it's just a fight yeah
it's just a what do you call it like a
sanction
for a title it's not like a gimmick
fight i'm a [ __ ] win
[Laughter]
that's nothing to do with gender it's
just win or lose because they didn't
know they didn't wasn't there a recent
mma fight that was everyone was watching
and and it was like a it was a guy
transitioned into a girl that got out of
special forces before yeah yeah and he
[ __ ] knocked that girl just destroyed
her he was fighting
okay
in a woman's league oh okay so she was
fine she was fighting in the women's
league you ever fire anybody from your
camp
my camp
my camp's only like
my two coaches
and then my coach's little son
so now
oh my god
what's your post fight ritual like what
do you do after you well since you've
been a professional after you knock
somebody out [ __ ] dead what do you
usually do afterwards after your fight
um the past two fights
i find in carson's side for that uh my
team and i and then family members went
to in-n-out
and then uh
sex
[Laughter]
that's what he meant by in and out
after that uh me my homeboy we went out
of that do you not have sex before a
fight not before the fight
yeah
if she's like what if she's like really
horny she's like please we have to i
mean like maybe like
three weeks before but
wow what's your cutoff three weeks
that's your cutoff damn
21 days undefeated baby how do you go
through training and [ __ ] like that
because like um and stay consistent when
you feel like [ __ ]
like there's times like you know we're
all human you know we [ __ ]
get sad you know what i mean like how do
you get up and you just like i gotta
train today i know i just find stuff to
motivate me like
think about money that i'm gonna get
paid or think about thinking about like
if i don't put in the work he's gonna be
putting in the work i'm gonna get tired
so you're constantly thinking about
competition and composition
this stuff that motivates me um and my
opponent too like and i'm always
thinking too like
that i want to do everything correct so
if anything does happen i can't blame it
i have nothing to blame at all you ever
had to do like a like um like a fighter
like um like it was like a crazy like
uh event and then [ __ ] happens in life
where it's like
[ __ ] man like [ __ ] my [ __ ] brother
got into car accident or whatever like
you ever got like where you had to
[ __ ] think
in the game but then your mind was like
[ __ ] no not recently when i was a
little kid i was like
10 or 12 maybe
uh i was sparring
so i i used to live up north so i drove
we drove down to the coachella valley
and we we sparred i think we got here
like on a friday and then i like [ __ ]
fractured my foot or something like
while i was sparring like i was like
bouncing and then the way i landed like
[ __ ] up my foot
and then i had a fight on saturday oh
[ __ ] and i [ __ ] and i
watched you have to get into an extra
mindset like how do you like how do you
not pull it out like [ __ ] it i'm uh i
think i was just a little kid i i i
don't know
i was a little kid i remember that and
then we went back and then my mom took
me to the doctor did you tell the kid i
whipped your ass with a broken body
so no one knew you had a broken foot
until wow
that's whoever you are
you extra extra loss was there was there
ever a time that uh you like what that
you felt like you really let your dad
down
oh [ __ ] we're getting we're getting soft
right now that's a hot that's a hot fish
that's not super hot i don't think so
damn damn that's six [ __ ] up in my dad
but it is a big fear of his though if i
call your dad right now let's see if
you're lying
oh my god
yeah you didn't do the dishes to this
morning let's see if you lie if you get
sponsored by any company
which company would be
let them know right now all right nike
let's go
come on nike damn it sends a couple of
extra larges too
[Music]
you